going to get started on time can you
hear me all right
bill is not here today he left early for
a Mia so I will introduce myself and
then I will introduce Skye my name is
Joe Nash and I'm a professor and the
Vice Chair in the department
my specialty is organizational behavior
and management and clinical systems
implementation and qualitative work I'm
going to start by talking about the
overall project we've been doing on
medical scribes and then I'll be
introducing you to Skye who is giving
her a a talk at a Mia next week so this
is her practice talk so I will try not
to take up all her time but we have had
a larger study going on for the past two
years we have a five-year grant through
arc to study the safety of the EHR in
the hands of medical scribes and these
are the folks involved in the study
particularly the qualitative aspect of
it our money is from arc and first of
all what is a scribe because they're
sort of new on the scene and not
everyone knows what they do or what
they're for
they're basically to do documentation
for providers so they are called often
documentation assistants
instead of scribes there's no specific
licensure for them CMS and the other
agencies provide no official guidelines
about scribes
although the Joint Commission just last
summer came out with some published
guidance so there is some action in this
area on the published guidance however
says that the Joint Commission neither
supports nor prohibits the use of
scribes so it's not really really
helpful but this is sort of a typical
set up for
scribe this is the scribe with a cart
following a provider it looks like
probably in the emergency department and
catching or trying to catch every word
the provider says sometimes we see them
running around literally what is the
problem alright we're not really sure
how safe it is for scribes to be using
the EHR since there are really no
qualifications except usually a college
degree although some scribes are college
students recently in JAMA internal
medicine there was this really nice
study up until 2017 there had been 60
studies published on scribes and since
then 23 studies have been published on
scribes so you see it's becoming a much
more active area for research but this
was a really excellent paper sort of the
cream of the crop just recently
published that really will convince you
that providers feel they're more
efficient with scribes and it's been
shown that they actually are so it's not
just a perception providers definitely
feel that they suffer less
burnout when they have scribes not only
do they work faster but they're less
annoyed or frustrated not having to use
the EHR as much and patients really do
appreciate having a scribe in the room
we think the jury is a little bit out on
that but they generally tend to respond
to surveys by saying that they like
having the scribe in the room if they
know it's a scribe in the room it's the
fastest growing industry in healthcare
again it's not regulated but in 2017
there were I'm sorry 2015 there were
20,000 scribes in the US and by next
year supposedly there will be a hundred
thousand so that's a pretty
good accelerating rate for this growth
of a new industry by industry we also
mean that that industry has moved into
it so that many places don't hire their
own scribes like we do here at OHSU many
scruggs are hired by companies and then
contracted out to organizations there
was an accompanying editorial in this
JAMA internal medicine paper issue by
our colleague David Bates and his
colleague at Harvard Adam Landman
commenting on the lovely study I just
mentioned and they said well scribes are
definitely an unintended consequence of
EHRs the industry did not start growing
at that rate until EHRs were being
rapidly implemented but they feel it's a
band-aid that it's a short-term industry
it will die at some point if and when
EHRs get good enough that providers will
want to use them they say at the same
time EHRs will be getting better that
documentation should be getting better
and they've documented that in other
countries often documentation as as half
as much as what we do here in the US so
they're making this a push for better
EHRs and better documentation and then
we won't need scribes we will see but
these are two papers I highly recommend
for our overall study we are starting
with a one describing activities of
medical scribes because this is a pretty
new area and we particularly want to
focus on their use of the EHR and how
safe is it to have these non-medical
people hands on the computer all day
long often entering orders and
other things that some people are a
little nervous about our ultimate goal
though is at the end of five years to
have some training modules that can be
put out there by arc and available to
anyone who needs scribes to be trained
we use the socio-technical model it's
based on the eight dimensional
socio-technical model that Dean sitting
and seen published but we've condensed
it into four different dimensions
because several of theirs were technical
so we put those technical ones together
and we made sure that we talked to
people who knew about these areas and we
asked them questions about these areas
it's a way of making sure you cover
everything and don't forget anything we
use the rapid assessment process that we
developed and sky will tell you a little
more about this but I particularly like
this picture because it's what we do we
do with good planning ahead of time an
ascension onto this and an organization
so decent I guess is what we would say
we go to sites carefully chosen around
the country for about a week and we look
at what they're doing and we talk to
people about what they're doing here's
the data you don't need to read it sky
has a better graphic for this but I just
want to show you that we did a lot so we
talked to over 80 people and we did over
80 hours of direct observation of scribe
provider teams working in many many
different environments not only the
emergency department and they're very
heavily used in emergency departments so
that's a bit of a different model from
when they're used for example an
outpatient setting where they really
work one-on-one all day with one
provider
in emergency departments they're drawn
from a pool so they get to work with
many providers on many many different
types of patient visits anyway we went
to five sites all around the country
with different characteristics and we
came up with ten things that fit into
these four different socio technical
dimensions and I'll go through them one
by one from the personal perspective
provider view the upsides our providers
really truly look like this when you
mention the word scribe I went to the
ophthalmologist two days ago and a
strange person came in the room when the
ophthalmologist was reading off all
these numbers and at the end of the
visit I said are you ascribe bad sky
right I mean the first lesson is the
provider is supposed to introduce the
scribe and she kind of snuck in and
started typing away she said yes and I
said well I'm doing some research on
scribes can you tell me what your
experience has been so they kept me for
15 minutes extra because they wanted so
badly to talk about how successful this
had been for them and truly that's what
they look like
providers really glow when they talk
about their scribes they value what the
scribes do for them they get to go home
hopefully earlier in the day they don't
have that particular frustration the
scribe fits into their individual
workflow nothing is forced upon them
over and over again we were told that
burnout can be avoided and we talked to
many providers who said I would have
retired years ago if the scribing thing
hadn't hadn't come along we even came
across some providers who had different
physical disabilities and they just
simply couldn't have practiced if they
didn't have a scribe helping them
they get to see more patients or they
get to shorten their day very often
they're forced to see more patients to
make it cost-efficient so the biggest
challenge is one of the models and the
most prevalent model is that these are
students very young bright students
headed to medical school or PA school or
nursing school and this is the stopgap
for them either they do it in college
before they apply or they do it as a gap
year and so the average is about a year
or so that they stay with someone you're
lucky if it's any longer than that so
constant turnover which is my theory for
why they have to use human resources
companies to organize them to do this
constant recruiting and training so
turnovers a big problem for everyone
individuals don't do all the training
usually the companies do a certain
amount of training but you as an
individual have to teach them how you
want to do things providers need
training - this was the biggest surprise
during our first site visit was how
badly providers needed to learn how to
really use scribes in a maximal way so
we found very often they were
underutilizing scribes or misusing
scribes and they really needed to learn
how to do it correctly and we were told
over and over again that sometimes they
may become over-dependent on scribes
there was some fear when we went out
there we feared that providers were not
learning how to use the HR if they just
depended on the scribes for everything
and there was only one site we visited
where the providers never touch the EHR
and they were very grateful they never
had to but every place else the
providers wanted to know the EHR they
were well trained in the EHR they valued
the scribe for other things and the
reason for that is usually they didn't
have a scribe all the time so if they
knew that during a week
would have several rotations where they
didn't have a scribe they had to use the
EHR from the scribe point of view it
kick-starts their medical careers and
helps them to get into Medical School
very often they can get good letters of
reference from the people they worked
with they get paid for something in the
past they may have volunteered to do and
it's very stimulating they're constantly
learning if they have a good provider to
work with and they're making a
contribution to healthcare
the pay is really bad about $12 an hour
even though the company might make 24 or
25 dollars an hour for that describes
one hour they get paid about $12 an hour
their hours they're assigned to if
they're color students in particular may
be difficult and providers vary and this
is where the training for providers
comes in because revisers sometimes are
not easy to work with let's just put it
that way
some scribes may actually have held back
though in our study because they were
all working they were all working either
for a company or an organization and we
felt they were holding back at times
from the patient view we did not talk to
patients we did not have IRB approval to
do that but we asked everybody we
interviewed what they thought patients
thought and many had Press Ganey scores
and many had done surveys of their
patients so what they told us was
actually patients really like this they
if they're introduced properly described
they understand makes it like in this
picture so that the provider can pay a
hundred percent attention to the patient
he has a laptop over there in the corner
but very often that's just so that he
can turn and show the patients something
on the screen he's not doing anything on
the laptop it's just there for his
convenience and the scribe is writing
everything down
the challenges proper introductions I'd
say maybe half the time we found proper
introductions not being made of course
some of the time patients were repeat
patients than they already knew that
this stranger was ascribed but other
times they they were puzzled by why the
scribe was in the room and some may feel
uncomfortable you know an
ophthalmologist I certainly didn't feel
uncomfortable having a scribe in the
room but there may be conditions where
you might feel uncomfortable having
described in the room training knowledge
and synthesis so training varies
depending on the model but companies
seem to do a pretty good job of training
they get maybe 40 hours of training a
little anatomy and physiology they
should already be good typist a little
bit about healthcare quite a bit about
HIPAA and such so they get that in a
sort of classroom setting and then they
get on-the-job training with a trainer
once they're assigned to a provider
providers usually don't get any kind of
training and a wonderful surprise to us
was that scribes are sort of supposed to
be like transcriptionists you know flies
on the wall the provider just tells them
what to put in to the EHR and you know
these are really short people and so
they're going beyond that and they're
synthesized synthesizing information so
that they're not just transcriptionists
they'll let the provider know who this
patient is what the issues are they'll
pull the information together for the
provider ahead of time we heard for
example that they'll look at care
everywhere and providers sometimes have
a hard time figuring out how to use it
that's the health information exchange
among epic users and since the scribes
are really really agile with a computer
they'll have everything I'll pull
together for the provider and they'll
say oh by the way and by the way and
don't forget this so they have knowledge
and after they've been on the job for
about six months they have this ability
to synthesize and they really truly we
saw all the time them helping the
providers reminding the providers oh you
promised the patient this don't forget
so the challenges though the training
has to be sufficient and it has to
include organizational training so many
of these industrial scribes those who
work for companies are well trained by
the company but then they're contractors
and so they're put into the organization
and they get no onboarding they get some
EHR training in the particular instance
of the EHR at that site but they don't
get truly onboard us so they don't
become part of the culture we we heard
this over and over again they sort of
feel out in left field because they're
just not part of the organization
they're not paid by the organization nor
have they been acculturated to the
organization and the training must be
ongoing
partly because usually the Turner over
is so rapid there often is not updated
training available for the scribes or we
also heard that scribes are forgotten
it's very sad
there you know when when epic training
comes along updated training comes along
the scribes will be forgotten in it
they'll forget to invite them so this is
the theme the scribe provider
interaction that screamed at us it was
not something we expected that this
would be so important and so complex and
sky picked up on this and it has made a
very in-depth study of it so I'll let
her talk about it again I think this
pair sort of symbolizes a good
relationship described industry as I
said it's the fastest growing medical
career there is and these companies have
jumped in to make money and provide the
human reason
tasks that are too much for the
organization's even so even with a
company making its money off it
organizations are finding that it's a
cost effective strategy for helping
their providers and of course they help
with a high turnover because they're
constantly constantly out there
recruiting and they know where to
recruit and how to recruit challenges
minimal regulation and little
standardization so scope creep is very
dominant in because there are no
standards we have talked to scribes who
have done things way out of scope
because they want to do them because
they wanted to come doctor someday and
their provider wants them to do them
because the provider needs help
and so a few stitches here and there
sure go at it so we did not study any of
these overseas models that are becoming
more heavily used because it's such a
growing industry it's been hard to keep
up and India has become a place
providing scribes they do have at least
one company I know of where they use
trained doctors as scribes this is a
company that has been advertising that
you can get complete medical scribe
training 40 hours and become a virtual
doctor which is you know pretty nice for
somebody who wants to go into medicine
ultimately they can become a virtual
doctor in just 40 hours we did not study
an overseas model but we did study a
virtual model at a clinic where they put
their scribes in a separate room next to
them so it was clear who the scribes
were who was acting as a scribe that day
it seemed very very efficient and those
were the providers who never had to
touch the computer
so we studied a virtual interesting
model but not an overseas model
compliance safety and risk this is why
we got into this in the first place was
to see how safe things were in the
scribe environments and the places we
went they're pretty darn careful about
the boundaries or they would not have a
scribe putting in stitches they they
were cognizant of the boundaries about
what scribes should be doing although
they pushed them sometimes you know we
saw scribes helping patients off exam
tables which they're not supposed to do
because they could get hurt
or they could hurt the patient it's just
not something a scribe is supposed to do
but it needed to be done and so we it's
little pushes pushing on the boundaries
smaller sites may not be as aware and in
prior studies I've seen things done by
scribes in small clinics that were out
of bounds providers and scribes are
always pushing these boundaries together
and the management is trying to rein
them in and providers may not review
everything once they become really
comfortable with a scribe when they
start trusting the scribe scribes Joop
and orders in many places for example
and obviously the provider is supposed
to be looking at those orders and
sometimes they don't do that very
carefully DHR scribes are really good at
it we had no complaints from the scribes
except that well we'd like to be updated
a little bit more often and don't forget
us in the training the HR forces some
standardization of care so that's a
really good thing
scribes force more standardization of
care that's a really good thing too and
scribes often become the experts and one
of our sites have them as epic super
users and we saw in the field all the
time providers asking
scribe for health providers asking the
scribe what he or she should do at this
particular point so they became at the
elbow on-site helpers with the EHR the
challenge is needing to invest the time
to develop templates they should be
doing that anyway but this really forces
them to system upgrades cause of
problems for everyone and we saw that in
action at different places but sometimes
the scribes knew about the upgrade and
and quirky things that were happening
and found workarounds and other scars
because they don't have this community
of scribes didn't know about those
things and so the community of scribes
that they had been closer they would
have shared little HR tips and tricks we
felt
eridan Oh makes another big surprise we
found that usually where there are work
rooms for the scribes and providers to
work together there nicely set up if
they have like you know computers next
to one another they have the ability to
talk back and forth after each patient
and it works really well
it's the exam rooms that were not design
this is a brand new you know brand new
career brand new industry and the exam
rooms mostly we're not designed to have
that extra person in there and so very
often they walked around with their
laptops and we saw I can't tell you how
many times we saw scribes like this
working typing I thought it looked like
four hours on one leg so they had to
type with two hands right there's no
place to put their laptop that's handy
they they want to look at what's going
on so they can understand what the
providers saying and so they use two
hands and they're there like with their
laptop on so we thought there might be a
potential for injury
for this we did have a physical
therapist on our research team after all
and the laptops themselves were often
sub-optimal either they were completely
unreadable and so small I don't know how
they possibly could do it or their
batteries didn't you know lasts long
enough and and they were there on the go
all the time running around with these
laptops workflow efficiency so scribes
really do make life more efficient for
the providers and their whiz-bang at
using the EHR shortcuts and the
templates and they take maximum
advantage of the EHR on the downside
they may slow the provider down if
they're inexperienced or mismatched with
the provider if they just can't work as
quickly as some of the providers we saw
who never stopped running quality of
documentation and coding this is another
really interesting from a technical
point of view issues about who does
better documentation providers or
scribes and everybody we talk to
of course you know they're all scribe
users we try to talk to non scribe users
but there we were at sites that had
scribes so everyone felt that the
scribes did a better job that
documentation was more accurate because
it was done while things were happening
it was done in real time it wasn't after
the visit when the provider had enough
time to do it so real time and they knew
the EHR well the scribes did and they
were very much trained on documentation
and always always really trained on
coding coding meaning billing so that
the billing became more accurate and
this makes organizations really happy
because usually more accurate billing
means higher billing so it's not just
that the scribes help you work faster
and see more patients which is good for
the bottom line
it's
so that they bill at a higher rate just
because they capture everything that
gets done and they give reminders to
make sure documentation is complete
challenges they have to see or be told
that something was done the site we went
to that was virtual was all done by
audio and so if a provider said
something the scribe often had to say
was at the left or the right side
because they couldn't see it
all the other sites we went to the
scribe was right in the room and could
see everything and again the provider
may not review the work carefully so
different models of scribing the
pre-professional model that's the term
we're using for these scribes who are
going to become healthcare professionals
at some point or at least start out
thinking that professional scribes and
sometimes these RMA's or nurses who
become scribes the the place where we
had virtual scribes they were all
professional they had gotten promotions
to become scribes in their organization
they had worked for the organization as
amazed or nurses they were well trusted
and then they were offered this higher
paid promotion to become a scribe most
of the time the scribes are considered
what's the term we're supposed to use
low man bottom of the hierarchy people
but this one model it worked very well
for them because they said not every MA
is gonna make a good scribe they have to
prove that they will so each model has
their strengths and weaknesses the model
has to fit the situation and because the
human resources challenges are so high
because of all the turnover the
companies really have stepped in to
provide that as a service we were a
little grumpy about the companies at
first you know our expectations going in
and talk
to people we're not the highest and
actually it turned out that there really
truly performing a service so there are
upsides and downsides from all of the
different dimensions or perspectives
there are best practices like
introducing the scribe it only takes 15
seconds and there's a way of doing it
you say this is the person's name this
is my scribe she's going to be doing
documentation for me so that I can pay
attention to you better like you sell
sell the person on the on the scribe and
say and it's your option to not have a
scribe in the room that's the right
thing to do is to say it's your option
not to have the scribe in the room so
it's a partnership between the provider
and the scribe and I'm going to turn it
over to Skye to talk about how you don't
want that to either be a provider or a
scribe on the left do you want this nice
happy serious discussion going on
between the two so Skye is going to
focus on the scribe provider interaction
I'm supposed to give you the microphone
and I will use that one turn it off
introduce sky because she was brought on
Jeff Gould is the PI of this big
five-year grant to study scribes vishnu
and i and robbie or other PI's on this
and Skye was hired as a research
assistant and project manager for
multiple studies she has a master's
degree in psychology and I was really
thrilled with having someone with that
background come on to our team she said
that she wanted to learn qualitative
methods and boy does she ever and then
as we were getting our results analyzed
she just thought this interaction part
which for a psychology graduate would
make sense was fascinating as I said it
was quite surprising to us how important
this was and so she took it and ran with
it
and she said I'd like to submit a paper
for a mia and she got it through the
whole process and when are you
presenting Wednesday so if any of you
are there please
attend the session on Wednesday I'll let
you take it away
cool you should be able to recognize two
characteristics that make for an
exceptional scribe user and lastly you
should be able to identify two positive
and two negative aspects to the scribe
provider relationship and me and Jones
presentation are gonna overlap a little
bit during the beginning stages so a
medical scribe is someone who assists
the provider with documentation and
performs tasks ideally within their
scope of responsibilities and as EHR use
has increased over the past decade
so has physician burnout and over
documentation and because of these
unintended consequences of the HR the
profession of medical describing was
born and as Joan mentioned scribe use
has grown dramatically and has been
described as a fastest growing
profession in medicine and literature
suggests that there are multiple
different scribing models available like
virtual model or easy ma earner
subscribes or the pre professional model
and while data suggests that scribes
increase the quality of billing
documentation their accuracy of their
notes and the scribes ability to perform
other EHR duties have not been well
characterized and our research team sent
out a national survey to health care
providers and found that there was a
wide variety in the type of scribing
model used the type of training utilized
as well as a wide variety inscribing
activities and because of this
variability found in the National Survey
our research team received a grant to
create a toolkit to transcribes how to
safely use the EHR the first steps of
our research were to figure out what is
happening in the field of scribing and
seeing what factors influence scribes
so we're overall objective of this
project was to use associated technical
model as a framework to understand the
current landscape of scribing and this
was supposed to help us better develop
our list of competencies which we would
use to inform our design of our toolkit
in the main objective of the
study is to further expand the knowledge
of the sky provider interaction and
describe this relationship dynamic from
October 2017 through January 2019 we
conducted five site visits around the
United States we use purpose of sampling
when selecting our sites because we
wanted the site's to differ in
geographic location size of the clinic
and hospital EHR vendor and scribe model
utilized and we ended up using the rapid
assessment process model to conduct our
methodology and this is known as rap and
rap is essentially a rapid qualitative
and ethnographic approach to aggregating
data and an important aspect of rap is
triangulation and triangulation uses
multiple perspective perspectives and
data points to enhance validity and
reliability of our data and for us we
use structured interviews observations
with field notes and we had a diverse
research team to offer interdisciplinary
perspectives and we use sittig and
seeing's eight dimensions of socio
technical model for health information
technology as a framework for
structuring our interviews and
observations with in vivo eleven we
coded our transcripts and iteratively
conducted a FEMA analysis using a
grounded approach so in my paper and
what Joan showed was a full table we
created that breaks down the
demographics from the site visit but for
the sake of this presentation I've
created a new table with information I
found the most pertinent and interesting
so we conducted 76 interviews with a
total of 81 people and we interviewed
scribes providers and administrators and
administrators were people like scribe
trainers clinic managers and scribe
managers we spent a total of 80 hours
observing at the five different sites
and we ended up visiting twelve clinics
which included urgent care emergency
departments family medicine auntie
sports medicine in pediatric cardiology
and as you can see most of our sites
used epic one site use all scripts and
one side had just switched from sir
EPIK a couple months prior to us coming
to visit in most of our sites utilized a
pre-professional model some of the sites
used a traditional third-party scribe
company and others had homegrown scribe
programs like OHSU and we visited one
site that used a virtual and ma model so
through this research we discovered ten
major themes which are depicted on the
screen in one aspect that kept popping
up in our data was the idea of the
scribe provider interaction theme and we
found this theme to be particularly
interesting because we felt like the
scribe and providers had one of the most
unique relationships in health care and
because of this we wanted to focus this
paper solely on this one theme and the
scribe provider interaction theme
basically explains how the providers and
the scribes work together in how their
relationship could improve and through
our qualitative analysis we found six
sub themes which are on the screen and I
will be discussing each of these sub sub
themes in depth for the remainder of the
presentation so during interviews and
observations people offered
characteristics they felt like an ideal
scribe should have and one of the ones
we heard the most often was effective
communication it was important for the
scribes to ask the providers to clarify
items
it was also pertinent for the scribes to
be able to speak up for themselves and
to be able to handle feedback in
criticism we heard from one scrub that
the more communication you have with
your provider the better it is for
everyone you also found was important
for scribes to be flexible and adaptable
many of these scribes are working with
multiple providers across multiple
different departments and they had to be
willing to match the clinical workflow
they were working in we also saw is
beneficial for the scribes to have some
sort of healthcare and medical
background and to be passionate about
medicine the scribes are working long
shifts in our learning complicated
medical terminology and have to have the
drive to really push through and lastly
we saw this important prescribe to be
professional and this was professional
in appearance as well as professional in
the patient room with the provide
and the patient one of the providers
told us that she wanted the scribe to be
a fly on the wall to Melton to the
corner to not be a part of the
conversation to be an observer our
second thing looked at the
characteristics of a good provider and
just like with medical scribes it was
important for the providers to
communicate effectively the scribes
mentioned it was beneficial when the
providers would say the exam findings
out loud in the patient room and clarify
aspects of the chart we also saw was
important for the providers to offer the
scribes feedback even negative feedback
because they wanted to improve we saw
was important for the providers to teach
the scribes when trying to find
providers to you scribes one
administrator said they look for that
doctor that has that teaching heart and
most of the scribes are there to learn
they want to be doctors themselves one
day and they feel like the more provider
is willing to teach them the better
charts they're able to produce for the
doctors we also saw that patience was a
key characteristic of a good provider
a provider must have patience because
sometimes the providers forget that it
is a human work in the computer and
because not everyone is perfect on their
first shift for a third sub-theme we
investigated provider variability and
what we saw was the providers of a
plethora of different styles of note
writing with vast variability and
because each provider varied with
documentation style the scrap started
developing document specific for each
provider that included the provider
preferences like smart phrases
terminology and templates and one scribe
told us that every provider is different
in knowing the preferences before you
walk in you will have a better shift if
you walk in not knowing who you are
working with or the Preferences it is
going to be a rough shift and knowing
the provider preferences was really
important with scribes who are working
across specialties with multiple
different providers and we did see that
some sites and specific departments had
standardized our note templates that way
all the providers and scribes were using
the same note template which seemed to
be beneficial prescribes
for our first sub for a fourth sub theme
we investigated the quality of the
scribe provider relationship and one of
the most important aspects of this
relationship was a high level of trust
one administrator told us if you don't
have the trust setup you are out of luck
because that's the foundation of
scribing and ascribing provider needs to
match each other as well
this included personality matches as
well as departmental matches and match
in the department's culture we also saw
that the scribe and provider must work
together as a team to be and to also be
a part of the larger health care team
and one provider told us it is crucial
to that relationship that the fifth at
the physician view the scribe as someone
who's a key member of the team for a
fifth sub theme we like that the
challenges associated with the scribe
provider interact oh yeah relationship
and one issue we heard about was having
the providers not reviewing the notes
thoroughly one administrator mentioned
that she saw scribes writing pretty
junky notes and the doctors were just
signing them not reading just sign sign
sign in despite organizations trying to
match the scribe and the providers
together mismatches still occurred we
saw personality mismatches as well as
departmental mismatches for example we
heard about scribes having a hard time
keeping up with the pace of urgent care
and would have been better suited in a
specialty that had longer patient visits
and we also heard about providers
becoming over dependent on their doctors
and one provider mentioned the cognitive
impact that scribing has on him he
mentioned that he remembered more of the
patient visit when he was around writing
the note himself and remembered less of
the patient visit wouldn't ascribe wrote
the note and we also saw issues with the
power gradient the first issue we saw
was that sometimes the scribes felt like
they were at the bottom of the hierarchy
with a provider at the very top and the
scribes don't had advocates for them
sometimes so they felt like they're not
part of the culture and are isolated
from the health care team and because of
the hierarchy differences between the
scribe of the provider the scribe saw be
asked to do something outside of their
scope of responsibility and feel
obligated to do it
we also heard about professional issues
that occurred between the scribe and the
provider where the provider would ask
the scribe to house it for them or run
errands for them all in promise of
writing a strong like read a letter of
recommendation for med school and for a
final sub-theme we investigated the
evaluation and supervision of scribes we
saw and heard that each scribe buried in
the amount of feedback offered to the
scribes and this feedback not only
varied between sites but also between
providers inside the same organization
some providers gave feedback at the end
of each encounter others gave feedback
at the end of the day and some never
gave feedback to the scripts at all and
when the providers didn't give the
scribes feedback a lot of them would
look at past notes and see what the
provider change so that they could try
and learn from their mistakes the issue
at that is that they lack the clinical
knowledge that doctors have to fully
understand why those changes were made
and while trust is a crucial aspect in
creating a strong relationship between
the provider and the scribe it also
plays a role in the amount of time the
provider has been devaluating the
scribes and what we saw and heard was
that his trust increases between
describing the provider the amount of
time the provider spins evaluating the
notes and the scribes performance
decreases and one provider told us that
you see you know 25 to 30 patients and
that you know three or four ships a week
I can't pour through everything so I
pretty much trust my scribe on the
history the physical the review of
systems and a scribe mentioned that over
time providers start to trust you and
know what you're writing and obviously I
didn't go to med school for twelve years
so I could have some errors in them in
my notes in the process for evaluating
the scribes performance varied between
sites and we said truly saw two
processes the first was reactionary
which meant that the scribe organization
only stepped in if the provider had
reported an issue with the scribe and
the second was a more proactive approach
where we saw quarterly or monthly audits
done of the scribes notes at random and
compared them to a gold standard note
and the provider would be allowed to
offer feedback on the scribes
performance as well
and for this discussion section I'll
talk about our next steps in future
directions and so in April of 2019 we
invited experts in various fields like
informatics in the scribe industry to
come to a conference we were hosting
where we discussed knowledge skills and
attitudes of scribes that we found in
our data from the five side visits and
we've taken their suggestions and are
working on a modified Delphi to further
develop these scribe competencies which
we will turn into the simulated video
activities for our toolkit and in the
past we also interviewed medical
students who used to be scribes to see
what sort of impact scribing had on the
medical career and we're in the process
of analyzing that qualitative data and
conducting a theme analysis and for
future directions we could look at the
pros and cons of different scribe models
which could help the organization
determine which model best suits their
needs and we could also look at future
directions like investigating which like
what are the best economics for the
scribe provider to have the most
efficient interaction and for conclusion
we learned that there is so much
variance of what it takes for the scribe
and providers to have a successful
relationship and our end goal is to try
and create some standardization through
our scribe toolkit so hopefully we will
be able to tackle some of this variance
and yeah thank you research team for all
your hard work on this project and I'll
be now taking questions with Jung
[Applause]
thanks so much both of you for this
great talk and really interesting area I
had two questions one was kind of maybe
a shorter one and that's what sense do
you have about how much scribes know
about billing codes E&M regulations on
that front of what needs to go into a
documentation in feel empowered to make
suggestions along those lines of this
needs to be there that doesn't those
kind of things so I guess knowledge and
empowerment on structuring documentation
to meet regulations it really varied
didn't it we saw some some sites where
the scribes were very knowledgeable in
the billing and coding aspects and then
other sites you know they just did the
documentation and they weren't like
really allowed to put the two and two
together you have anything to add the
site that seemed to do it best taught
them a lot but had very standardized
templates mostly for the emergency
department yeah and they knew what they
needed to put in to the documentation so
that the billing would be automatically
done correctly so that's that's the
tie-in was that they didn't actually put
in billing codes but they knew they had
to put something in here or the billing
wouldn't happen and they did know you
know what the different levels were and
they tried to be thorough enough so that
they could code at the highest level
yeah and then the second question I had
was along the lines of how to improve
scribe provider interactions and what
interventions you think will be most
effective for that I can see some base
knowledge of like whenever you interact
with the scribe and Joan you talked
about introductions and just those kinds
of things to train in but it also seems
like as you mentioned with every new
scribe you have to learn how to
re-establish those kinds of things and
so maybe a one-time intervention of
training may not be the best so much as
every onboarding activities you did
together whatever it may be so I'm
wondering what interventions you
think might be most effective well I
think what would be ideal is if we're
creating this toolkit for scribes it
would be great if we could create one
for providers as well so that they know
how to safely and efficiently use a
scribe which I think would help improve
their interaction so back to like video
training providers activity like
learning activities even like lectures
like all different types of material
yeah ideally I just think they need to
become conscious of the importance of
this particular relationship this is
someone they're working with right at
their elbow really truly for long
periods of time and so it's not like
some other members of the healthcare
team who pop in once in a while this
relationship is really important and the
providers need to understand some things
like this person wants to learn and it's
it would behoove you to take a few extra
seconds to give them an explanation
hi great job this is this is really
informative and and nice my question was
actually around the the scribes that
were reporting that they felt that they
were at the bottom of the hierarchy was
that like an outlier or was that a
general kind of consensus that they felt
left out of the the the social medical
support system in there or and is that
something that is being addressed so one
of the like places we saw it was it was
a third party scribe company and so they
were already you know not part of the
established health care team and so for
them they liked they felt like they were
just totally separated and we did talk
to other sites where they realized that
the scribes were very separated from the
rest of the healthcare team culture and
they were trying to you know bring them
more in like having them be a part of
fire drills and stuff like that so it
really varied but it seems like overall
sites are trying to improve on that so
there's less of that feeling
hi great job both of you I apologize if
I miss this piece but because I have had
a couple of very horrible scribe
provider interactions as a patient here
at OHSU where the provider didn't even
look at me I'm wondering and this is a
huge a big thing but I am interested to
know about how the patient perspective
can feed into this because while I know
we're focused on helping providers do
their work better and and then also
helping the scribes to grow in their
careers and whatnot I also don't want to
forget about the patient perspective of
this and I don't know if there's in my
Press Ganey surveys I always write down
exactly what I think and I talk about
the scribe situation and what that feels
like and I don't know if there's any I
don't know the only way to even
incorporate that I mean not in this
particular project but was that brought
up anywhere can you tell us more about I
won't mention a name but yes I'm glad to
share my experience nope the computer
this provider sits down at the computer
and proceeds to complain about it while
the scribe is sitting there supposedly
ascribing whatever they're supposed to
be scribing and the provider does not
interact with me like very little when
we get funding to produce training for
providers won't that be good yes that's
that's a that's a great answer Joan
thanks do you feel like the scribe made
that better worse or the same I really
wanted to ask the scribe really I really
really did I it was it was a fascinating
triangle it wasn't a triangle it was a
fascinating experience and the provider
was actually documenting I don't know
what in the chart during the exam and
the scribe was also typing so I don't
know where that work was parsed out my
instinct is that the provider was
focusing on orders and Diagnostics at
list and those to medical
decision-making tasks and possibly
describe was strictly just starting a
parish note and just being a dictaphone
just typing whatever was said so so I
think it's an interesting piece of this
whole puzzle is what is the patient
experience in addition to asking is it
okay if if a scribe you know is is with
us there have been a couple of surveys
aside from Press Ganey surveys we have
copies actually of some survey
instruments that have been used with
patients and the results generally show
very positive but not always so there
are are some patients who don't like
having another person in a crowded room
already or if it's a delicate visit they
don't want that person in the room which
is why providers have to give them that
option but sometimes dong and so the
persons in the room and the patient
complains about it afterwards
just curious were they sharing the same
computer or did they each have separate
computers or how did that dynamic play
out they each had separate computers the
provider was working on the workstation
that is in the exam room and the scribe
had a laptop thank you
I was wondering if you have where if you
have plans to actually look at the
documentation that the scribes have done
and comparing it to the documentation
that providers might do in the same
situation actually yeah so it's not
mentioned but we're working on gathering
what is it vision you like hundreds of
thousands of documents of the scribe and
providers documentation and we're kind
of gonna run through and compare them
and see we're gonna see what
Commission's omissions and like
grammatical changes are made we're
trying to develop this through like the
Python code or something more efficient
because me and my coworker we're doing
this hand like one by one by hand and we
got 250 and it took us a long time so
yeah we're in the process of figuring
that out well thank you and there has
been one published study I'll share with
you if you remind me out of mayo no
Cleveland Clinic where they looked at
documentation through chart like did
chart review and showed positive results
for scribes great thank you
thank you this is really interesting I
have two questions first is do you know
if there is anything that third party
vendors that no that I guess the
companies do they do any revaluation and
I'll describe making sure that it is to
up to standard or something like I
didn't know that's no standard but like
do they actually review the work of the
obscure first of all all the way just
get like a evaluation from providers
that well you your providers like you or
don't like you whatever
second of all have you got a sense when
you were talking to describe the reason
why they're not part of the team because
of the high turnover so they never
really got enough time to be exposed to
the team to become part of the team well
well for the second part of it yeah I
didn't think about that but you're
probably right that turnover would play
a big part because some scribes are only
there for six months and so they might
not have the you know amount of time to
really build up and be a part of the
team like I think that could be accurate
but what was your first part of the
question
I'm sorry so this is about a third party
scribe companies do they do anything to
evaluate the scribe and how do they you
should approach that idea other than the
fact I mean I'm pretty sure they they
ask provider how do you like your scribe
but other than that do they do anything
more sophisticated and add variation
again in the companies there was one
company that had evaluation down so it
very well yeah it was just very
regimented and done every month and they
were giving constant feedback to even
the more seasoned scribes they were
giving tailored training even to this
more seasoned scribes when they
identified something that they weren't
doing quite up to snuff they they were
just a model I think
evaluation the biggest scribe company in
the world on the other hand doesn't do
as detailed a job I would say they
pretty much do depend on the provider
complaining or a clinic manager often is
the one who does the interface because
of the contracting with the third-party
company and so a provider will be grumpy
and the clinic manager then will reach
out to the scribe company and the scribe
company will send someone to the clinic
to figure things out yeah it was very
much you could tell the provider was the
customer and the scribe was the thing
they were selling and so they didn't
really care too much about how the
scribe necessarily was or anything like
that but cared about yeah there was one
instance though where well the provider
and the scribe were unhappy and the
manager overheard a lot of this because
they had two very different political
beliefs yeah imagine that and it got so
the manager contacted the scribe company
and the scribe company found someone
else and put that scribe someplace else
so they truly do work really hard on
matchmaking very personal matchmaker
yeah
I have a question when you presented the
ideal characteristics for describe in a
provider one of the things I notice is
there's kind of a competing priority
right so one for describe one of the
ideal characteristics is being a fly on
the wall not being interactive observing
and what provider it's teaching
traditionally when your physician
teacher you kind of bring them in you
show them physical findings it's very
engaging how do you kind of draw the
line between you know do I just tell
them more about the risks and benefits
and kind of talk about talk about things
without bringing them over and showing
them their edema or their murmur like is
there guidance for that and how to
interact with them good question um
typically what we saw was that inside
the exam room that's when they were a
fly on the wall and then it was outside
of the exam room and they was just the
provider inscribed they would you know
look at charts look at labs and talk
about things and that's when the
provider would really get to teach the
scribe would you agree Joan yeah yeah so
I just wanted to ask
Nats question did you notice a
difference between how well integrated
the scribes were and how integral they
were to the clinic based on whether it
was like a homegrown scribe program
versus a third-party vendor it's really
hard to answer that because one of the
vendors was homegrown so one of the
places we went the emergency department
providers set up their own scribe
company and the scribe company when we
were there was selling at services
outside but primarily inside this health
particular health care network and so it
was homegrown and completely excellent
with the others
I'll let you speed it that well I don't
know with some well we did see with one
of the places they kind of treated their
scribes like royalty like John mentioned
the virtual ma model how it was in honor
to become a scribe like it was valued
really highly and more yeah more pay and
like it was definitely like a step up
and with like a third-party vendor you
know they're being paid like $11 $12 an
hour so the company's very a great deal
yeah but as far as like how the
providers welcomed or didn't welcome the
scribe did they have a different
perception in terms of you're just
somebody that someone else has brought
in versus your our you know you're one
of us at some most places I'd say there
was scribe Envy so that not everybody
could have a scribe and those who didn't
have a scribe and be those who got a
scribe it was a valuable commodity
was their brother ever did any issues
with providers like describing physical
exam findings that were either
embarrassing or delicate for the patient
or that the patient became concerned
because they interpreted something is
being notable or concerning when the
provider was really just saying here's
what you need to write down yeah we did
see it wasn't like it's more of a best
practice because we didn't see everyone
do that when we were studying the e DS
the actually the script the provider
never said any of the exam findings out
loud he always left to go back to the
room and would say them all to the
scribe we just heard from scribes that
it would be beneficial if the provider
would do that but the reason they didn't
do that is because of yeah they were
worried about sensitivity and saying
something and bringing the patient out
so and we were not allowed to observe
anything that was going to be sensitive
anyway that's true all right I guess we
should wrap it up thank you so much for
coming